R
TO RUSSIA'S ADVANCING LINES.
ONE THAT IS ALREADY IN RANGE OF
ITS HEAVY WEAPONS.
TAKE A LOOK.
THERE IS NO EASY SAFE WAY TO
THE MOST EASTERN FRONT LINES OF
THE DONBAS.
RUSSIA HAS CUT THE HIGHWAYS.
SO SOLDIERS, WEAPONS, LOCALS
AND AID DELIVERIES MUST ALL
TAKE THE BACK ROADS.
THIS RED CROSS OPERATION IS --
THE SMALL TOWN CLOSEST TO THE
REGION'S MOST INTENSE FIGHTING.
THAT TEAM UNLOADS, VERY QUICKLY
FAMILIES ARRIVED TO LOAD UP.
THE NOISE OF WAR, CLOSE IN
LOUD.
NOBODY REACTS.
NATALIYA IS COLLECTING FOOD FOR
A HUSBAND AND TWO CHILDREN.
SHE SAYS THEY CANNOT LEAVE THE
TOWN BECAUSE THEY FEAR LOSING
THEIR HOUSE AND THEIR VEGETABLE
GARDEN THAT THEY RELY ON TO
SURVIVE.
>> ONLY A FOOL IS NOT SCARED
SHE SAYS.
BUT THERE IS NO WAY OUT AND WE
CANNOT LEAVE OUT.
>> LOU BARBER ARRIVES WITH THE
YOUNG CHILDREN.
SHE SAYS THAT THEY ARE SAYING
THAT THE RUSSIANS ARE PROCESS
BECAUSE THEY DOES NOT WANT TO
RISK BEING SEPARATED FROM THE
ELDEST DAUGHTER WHO LIVES IN
THE NEARBY VILLAGE.
>> SHE SAYS I CALLED HER ONCE,
SHE TOLD ME THEY ARE NOT
LEAVING AND THEN WE LOST
CONNECTION.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW IF SHE IS
OKAY.
.
--
THE SHOW US THE HOME WHERE SHE
HOPES THEY CAN SAFELY WAIT OUT
THE WAR.
IT IS A WAR LOOK TO THE OTHER
SIDE OF TOWN.
AND THEY SOON REALIZED, THAT
WILL NOT BE POSSIBLE.
THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD IS UNDER
FIRE.
INCOMING ARTILLERY FROM
SOMEWHERE CLOSE.
WAS SO CLOSE, YOU HEAR THE
ARTILLERY CEASE FIRE.
AND THE PROJECTILES FLY BEFORE
IMPACT.
THEY SHELVES FALL WITHIN THE
SAME TIGHT AREA.
AGAIN.
AND AGAIN.
WE SAW ALL OF THIS WHILE ON A
LITTLE FURTHER TO THE EAST,
RUSSIAN FORCES WERE CLAIMING AN
IMPORTANT WIN.
TAKING THE CITY OF LYSYCHANSK.
>> YES, COME TO US.
GOOD TO GO?
THE BATTLEFIELD IS ON A SHORT
DISTANCE FROM HERE.
THIS IS LIKELY TO BE THE FRONT
LINE VERY SOON.
ALREADY, RUSSIA'S HEAVY WEAPONS
ARE FALLING AMONG THESE
PEOPLE'S HOMES IN THIS TOWN.
IT'S NOT SAFE TO STAY.
ALL OF THESE PEOPL